Alarmierende Zahlen kommen diese Woche aus
Paris. Wir sind Zeuge des sechsten großen
Massenaussterbens, verursacht durch den Menschen.
85 Prozent der Feuchtgebiete sind zerstört,
die Hälfte der Korallenriffe ebenso, neun
Prozent der Nutztierarten sind ausgestorben,
die Biomasse der wild lebenden Tiere ist um
82 Prozent zurückgegangen, 23 Prozent der
Landflächen auf der Erde sind totes Land,
sie sind ökologisch heruntergewirtschaftet
und können nicht mehr genutzt werden. Undsoweiter
und sofort. Können wir die Erde und uns noch
retten? Clixoom Science & Fiction Hier gibt
es täglich spannende Wissenschafts-Videos,
abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts. herzlich Willkommen
Das hier hat mir Panikmache leider nichts
zu tun. Das weltweit höchste Gremium von
Wissenschaftlern lässt die Alarmglocken schrillen:
„Die globale Rate des Artensterbens ist
mindestens um den Faktor zehn bis Hunderte
Male höher als im Durchschnitt der vergangenen
zehn Millionen Jahre, und sie wächst", so
der gerade veröffentlichte Bericht des Biodiversitätsrats
IPBES der Vereinten Nationen. Wir stehen an
der Schwelle zur Vernichtung unseres Planeten.
Und wir merken es ja auch selbst. Verglichen
mit früheren Zeiten gibt es viel weniger
Insekten, was wir sehen, wenn wir mit dem
Auto schnell fahren und kaum noch Insekten
die Windschutzscheibe verschmutzen. Da haben
wir ja auch schon drüber berichtet. Und über
diesen Rückgang der Insekten, den wir selbst
erleben, gibt es noch keine globalen Studien.
Über den wird in dem Bericht noch nicht mal
eine definitive Aussage getroffen. Anders
ist das bei Vögeln, Amphibien und Säugetieren.
Hier ist der Rückgang beängstigend. „Die
Gesundheit der Ökosysteme, von denen wir
und andere Spezies abhängen, verschlechtert
sich schneller als je zuvor." So der Leiter
des Reports Sir Robert Watson. So würden
die Grundlagen von Einkommen, Ernährungssicherheit,
Gesundheit und Lebensqualität beseitigt werden.
Sprich, die Folge wird das Aussterben des
Menschen sein. Und die Hauptursache ist die
Landwirtschaft. Und das ist wirklich paradox.
Die (man muss leider Industrie sagen), die
uns eigentlich ernähren soll, zerstört unsere
Lebensgrundlagen. Die Landwirtschaft würde
durch Subventionen daran gehindert Lebensmittel
umweltfreundlich zu produzieren, so die Wissenschaftler
und Wissenschaftlerinnen. Bundesumweltministerin
Svenja Schulze nennt unter anderem die EU-Agrarsubventionen
als Grund. Eigentlich ein gutes Instrument,
um die Unabhängigkeit der EU von Lebensmittelimporten
zu sichern, führen sie jetzt zur Zerstörung
der Erde."Es kann keiner mehr sagen, wir haben
es nicht gewusst", das sagt Josef Settele
vom Helmholtzzentrum für Umweltforschung
in Leipzig. Und das ist wirklich der Punkt:
Es handelt sich hier um belastbare wissenschaftliche
Erkenntnisse aus Unmengen an Studien. Es ist
wissenschaftlich erweisen und Politiker und
Politikerinnen, die diese Erkenntnisse nicht
sofort in die Tat umsetzen, sind tatsächlich
ein Gefahr. Der Bericht gibt jetzt zahlreiche
Empfehlungen, was getan werden müsse. Im
Oktober 2020 findet der Weltnaturschutzgipfel
im chinesischen Kunming statt. Dann müssen
dort dringend Entscheidungen getroffen werden.
Es geht hier nicht um die Naturliebhaberei,
sondern um unser Überleben. Und auch wir
können ganz konkret etwas jetzt sofort verändern:
Wir können am 26. Mai zur Europawahl gehen
und zweitens genau die Partei wählen, die
die Standpunkte vertritt, die jetzt wichtig
sind und unser Überleben sichern. Wir sind
diejenigen, die entscheiden! Also laßt es
uns tun! Hashtag #diesmalwahleich Mehr dazu
im Video der Tagesschau Wahl-O-Mat für die
Europawahl - da findet man die richtige Partei
mit ein paar Klicks Also anklicken und anschauen
würde ich mal sagen! Wir sehen uns am 26.
Mai im Wahllokal. Bis dann, bleibt dran!